Chris says should I buy a $9,300
tempur-pedic mattress with interest-free
financing I have to think you're being
sarcastic otherwise I think you're
stupid beyond words and so I'll have to
go with sarcastic tongue-in-cheek
question right just this is the stir up
Dave Ramsey question right see if we can
get Dave ranting so I mean what else is
Facebook for I mean really seriously
so we'll answer it as if it were a
serious question by a stupid person so
oh god really seriously if you want to
pay $10,000 for your bed you should
first have a lot of money which would
thereby mean that you were not even
asking this question so I'll just go
ahead and start with you can't afford
this mattress and otherwise if you could
afford this mattress you would have
never asked this question but no we
don't buy anything on that ever in any
circumstance interest free or otherwise
if you cannot pay cash for it
don't buy it okay that's a little
extreme let me get you take that $10,000
invested and and listen if you need to
worry about investing $10,000 you don't
need to be buying a $10,000 mattress if
investing a 10 $10,000 is going to
change your life then you don't need to
be buying a $10,000 mattress
meaning if you got a million dollars
invested $10,000 doesn't change your
life much and you could probably afford
to write a check and buy 10,000 other
mattress right and not think anything
about it if you want to do that but if
$10,000 is such a big freaking deal that
you have to do an analysis on it
mathematically then that by definition
means you don't need to be spending it
on a mattress under any circumstances
financed or otherwise if you have to
have this discussion it's kind of like
if you have to
that's the price you can't afford it you
ever heard that that's kind of where
this falls into that category
this is like an uber luxury item $10,000
from mattress is an uber luxury item
this is the freaking Bentley of
mattresses and you don't need to drive a
Bentley when you're broke even if it's
int interest-free and so here's the
thing as we've studied millionaires
people who actually have money not who
people who have a theory about money but
people who actually have money we have
found that there are two primary things
that they do they invest consistently
because number two they don't borrow
money they don't have any payments they
do not borrow money and therefore they
have money to invest consistently and
therefore they became wealthy it really
is a fairly simple formula but we
complicate it because we have this
little child down inside of us the one
that throws a temper tantrum on the
cereal aisle you ever seen that kid he
lives inside of every one of us his name
is immaturity his name is I want it and
I can't afford it
big hat no cattle be in but be HNC big
hat no cattle be HNC hashtag be HNC
right big hat no cattle these are a
bunch of immature children walking
around inside of every one of us one
definition of maturity is learning to
delay pleasure adults devise a plan and
follow it children do what feels good
so no Chris you should not buy a $9,300
tempurpedic bed with interest-free
financing you can't afford it by virtue
of this fact simple fact you asked this
question tells us you actually cannot
afford it